was that will smith
chris rock makes a joke about will smith
after dave chappelle was attacked on
stage mystery
history
the 48 year old's comedian was tackled
mid-set on tuesday night as he performed
at the los angeles hollywood bowl as
part of the netflix is a joke festival
the los angeles police department
confirms to e.t that the suspect
identified as 23 year old isaiah lee
jumped on stage armed with a handgun
replica that included a knife blade
security immediately intervened and
police tell us that the suspect was
detained booked on thirty thousand
dollars bail and charged with assault
with a deadly weapon after being taken
to the hospital with superficial
injuries
pretty good
well after the super tense mid show
moment rock who performed at the
festival before chappelle returned to
the stage to make a joke naturally
asking
was that will smith
of course that was a reference to when
smith slapped rock during the 2022
oscars after he made a joke about the
oscar winner's wife jada pinkett smith
a source tells et that rock was not on
stage when the attack occurred but as
soon as he realized what all the
commotion was about he immediately went
over to check on chappelle and without
skipping a beat made that joke about the
king richard starr
was that will smith
and get this jamie foxx was there and
e.t source says that he stepped in to
help the security when it all went down
chappelle even called him out on stage
to say thank you
shout out to jamie foxx by the way
whenever you're in trouble
jamie foxx will show up in the sharon's
hat
i thought that was part of the show
meanwhile an eyewitness tells et that
security was tight at the show and adds
that guests had to walk through two
checkpoints to get into the backstage
area and hanging out backstage according
to et's eyewitness jay-z beyonce busta
rhymes de baby rihanna and asap rocky
were there too
but the eyewitness adds that riri who is
expecting her first child with rocky did
not get caught up in the chaos on stage
explaining that they were nowhere near
the attack and left shortly after
history
as for chappelle we're told he was hit
in the ribs and was in shock but handled
it like a pro
i've been doing this 35 years
i just stopped in the backstage
always wanted to do that
and on wednesday fellow comedian jay
farrow did an impression of the funny
man on instagram singing a remix of kirk
franklin's song stomp uh in light of
these recent events
i want to sing my favorite song i can't
explain it
i can't attain it
i saw that
and it felt amazing
[Music]
you